the second largest Ebola outbreak in the
world has killed nearly 2,000 people in
the Democratic Republic of Congo in just
a year now two out of four new Ebola
vaccinations being tested are proving so
effective they're being given to all
patients in DRC on Tuesday two people
were given the all-clear and released
from a treatment center in Goma
officials with the World Health
Organization which has been coordinating
the trials hopes this will stem the
spread of the disease but the timing of
the treatment is vital those who
received treatment early so within the
first three days the mortality rate with
Regeneron
and ma b was around 10% comparison to
those patients who got treatment late
mortality rate for those due to drugs
are 60 or respectively 66% scioscia huge
difference whether you receive treatment
in the first three days or late the
vaccinations work by attacking the Ebola
virus with antibodies and neutralizing
its impact on human cells they were
developed using cells harvested from
Ebola survivors Ebola has killed at
least 13,000 people since 2013 besides
his say they're getting close to turning
it into what they call a preventable and
treatable disease and while it's
difficult to eradicate Ebola completely
with this medical breakthrough at least
doctors hope to put an end to outbreaks
that pose a major international health
threat Sarah Hyland al-jazeera